I believe in the power of conversation
to get human beings to converge on a
common project in which in which people
can collaborate in an open ended way,
in a non divisive way,
in a way that that never requires a,
an appeal to violence.
And,
and we have that in science.
We have that in much of intellectual
discourse.
We very much don't have that in
religion.
It's just there's nothing that a
fundamentalist Christian and a
fundamentalist Muslim can say to one
another to put their beliefs on the
table for,
for revision.
I mean they,
this is what dogmatism is.
It is,
it is a willingness to believe things
for bad reasons and an unwillingness to
have your rather tenuous reasons
challenged.
I mean,
it's,
you,
you're,
you were saying,
I believe this.
No matter what anyone else says.
So that's,
that's the antithesis of conversation.
It really is a,
a conversation stopper.
And so that's,
um,
that's why I paint a very stark
difference between faith and reason.
I mean,
reason if you're a reasonable,
if you're interested in how the world
works and what is true altogether,
you are open,
you're by definition open to,
to further conversation,
to more argument,
to more evidence and your,
you're in fact interested to find out if
you're mistaken about anything,
if you are not predisposed to that,
that open ended conversation.
Um,
you really have,
you have rendered yourself immune to
influence from the world that influenced
apart from just having someone,
you know,
pull out the guns on you.
I mean,
so there are certain people because of
their dogmatism who have made themselves
impossible to talk to.
I mean there's nothing that you're going
to say to,
to,
to get a Sama bin Ladin to reconsider
his view of the world.
And it's a unique feature of religion
that we defend this mode of being in a
religious context in a way that we would
never tolerate it in another context.
I mean,
if you're,
if somebody has medical beliefs,
you know,
if your,
if your doctor says,
you know,
I know this,
this,
this cures cancer,
but you know,
I'm not going to tell you how or why or,
or um,
you know,
I'm not going to have my data
challenged.
I mean,
this is,
that's a mode of talk within a medical
context that you would never get through
medical school,
appealing to those kinds of,
of,
uh,
intuitions.
Um,
it,
that really is the core of faith based
religion.
This idea that there are certain things
like that.
The Bible is the perfect word of God or
the Koran or the perfect word of God
that just have to be accepted,
cannot be challenged.
Uh,
and in certain context,
certainly within the Muslim world,
you can die for calling those
certainties into.
I mean,
it literally is a capital offense to
wonder whether the Koran may not be the
perfect word of the creator of the
universe.
I mean,
it's just,
and it used to be a killing a fence
within Christianity.
It's just,
it's just we have moderated the western
religion,
Judaism and Christianity to a remarkable
degree because of the last 200 years of,
of scientific and political problem.